we're back with the Property Brothers
all right you guys are the kings of home
renovation and we actually have an
audience member here who would love to
solicit your help and by the way I am
with you I always want to ask you guys
your advice and help but today Diva
where are you we don't work with divas
[Laughter]
now
Siva I'm so glad that you're
participating with us today what's your
design dilemma yes so my entryway is
super small and narrow but it's the
first point everyone sees into my home
so I want it to look nice but like my
jackets and my shoes and my bags alone
take up half the space so I really want
a space that feels functional but also
welcoming that is something I think so
many people can relate to because your
front entry is the width of your door
essentially there's a little extra on
the side there and so the biggest
challenge is part of it is your day to
day how do you keep it functional but
also when you're entertaining sometimes
you like to put a little bit more away
so this is the perfect opportunity to do
something where you have a fold away
bench or fold away hooks so that when
you want to declutter you can completely
capture that space back but it still
looks good also it's the first
impression anybody has of your home you
got to do something with that door that
whitewash door that you can see
fingerprints on no good so something
like painting out the door black would
be beautiful on the inside carry that up
the rail as well because a white rail I
think always looks kind of dirty too I
think it's important to have a little
bit more color in there which is why I
think a wallpaper would be incredible
you could do one wall that continues up
the stairwell and you know you can do a
peel and stick product so it's not like
it's something you could tackle yourself
we actually have
rendering that Jonathan and Drew have
done and I want to show it to you right
now and I think it's gorgeous wow so
just to give you an example to carry the
wallpaper and that's your wallpaper and
you know what we'll give you our
wallpaper so you can you can pick the
selection of what you like anything you
want you can pick wallpaper we'll give
it to you yeah
[Applause]
here's one other cool thing John's and I
were talking about Innovation as well
for more storage because you can never
have enough shoe storage I have a lot of
shoes
I'm a shoe gal uh one thing we were
thinking if you're able to do it because
it depends on some rentals or some
buildings have restrictions but in your
stairs the riser for your stairs you
could actually pull it out and put
drawers in so your bottom few steps
could actually have extra drawers look
at this Runner you can see the bottom
there we do it as a blind push latch so
you don't even see a handle or anything
when you want to access those shoes you
just push on it the Riser comes out and
you have full depth storage underneath
the steps okay that's why you guys
stair storage my mind is blown right now
I like the foldable idea the brothers
are going to give you their wallpaper
and cover your walls that's going to be
a great start then we're going to give
you a thousand dollars to get your
we're going so we've got wallpaper we've
got some cash and this way you can go
take this conversation marinate on it
and express yourself in your entryway
make it a dream and drink yeah
it's everybody's first impression of
your home what makes you happy every
time you walk in the door so go from
there that's what I would say absolutely
right good luck
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you